ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
studio this is actually my
second time filming this i am your host
your internet detective but i'm sad to
say
um i just found out that three of my
video files that were planned
were corrupted because i muted my mic
somehow uh so
get some coffee guys because uh i'm
gonna pull a late night here try to get
some more content out for you guys
because there's no way in hell
i'm going bald this month let me tell
you right now guys today i want to talk
to you this throwback thursday if you
don't know what day it is just so you
know that's why we do this throwback
thursday
hello you're almost at the end of your
week hang in there on thursdays as you
guys know we go back in time
to learn the lessons of scammers so we
can learn not only about them
but also ourselves a little bit of
psychology of
who we are and together we can be a more
educated population
fall for scammers less and in general
learn to empathize with each other more
i don't know if this show actually does
any of that but uh it's aspirational
guys today we're talking about the dark
truth
about conmen something that i've kind of
had to come to grips with because you
know on the show we kind of make fun of
these people we put paint them in the
worst possible light but there's a truth
that i've been avoiding
about the true con men listen there are
kind of your bottom feeding conmen
but then there's the top tier and at the
highest tier
what i haven't been addressing and what
is so uncomfortable to admit
is how likable con men are
and i know you're saying steven no these
guys are they're they're scammers no no
it's okay to admit the truth which is
that
if you watch look i was watching the
napoleon hill
interview right because i did that last
throwback thursday and one thing i came
away with is look if you can just strip
away
that the lying the the fake success
the fact that he was totally phony with
it all
this man is actually extraordinarily
likable i hate to say it and remember
before you begin writing
that your online limitations are those
which you set up in your own mind or
permit others to set up for you i mean
he's just kind of this uh
humble looking guy i'm not saying he's
some kind of saint or anything like that
but i'm saying if you listen to him
without knowing all the backstory about
him
you'd find him to be likable you'd find
him to be oh this is a guy i'd like to
be friends with
that is what is so difficult to deal
with with conman
is that the reason people get involved
with a lot of these scams and the reason
they keep going back to them
is because of the charisma and the cult
of personality a lot of these characters
so we're going to be going through
some history with a lot of different
characters like this so
i can make this point to you of really
how dangerous
this kind of thing is and with that i'd
like to turn
to perhaps the most troubling modern
version of this that i've seen
ladies and gentlemen this is joseph
james a trading instructor
on youtube now before i tell you what he
did let's just
watch one of his videos and just pay
attention to how this guy acts
all right guys back to work tonight
tuesday evening it's january the 12th
2020
my name is joseph and as always welcome
back to your nightly newsletter
first impressions great if you guys met
this guy in the street you didn't have
any context he wasn't featured in a
coffeezilla video
you'd probably find this guy likable
maybe a little chatty a lot of these
guys are a little bit chatty
but uh you know they're high energy
smiling
you can't probably see it with the black
and white but he's got these blue eyes
just hypnotizing me
bringing me in telling me this is a guy
i can trust
that's actually how you card people
actually is by being and appearing
trustworthy this is something hard for
people to accept
and the reason i finally wanted to
address it is because i keep getting the
same email basically saying hey
what do you think of this guy i think he
might be a scam but he's so
likable as if con men are supposed to
come out and tell you that they're
conman
as if they're supposed to wear like a
dark robe and like you know a wizard hat
and announce themselves
no that's kind of the point they're
likeable but of course you go
through he's thinking what actually does
he do behind all this aff ability what's
actually the end result
well oh look at this he pitches you a
course
every day at eight o'clock eastern time
monday through friday
i'll put the link you need the
description of this youtube video
i'll also put a big button for you to
click on the trading blog so
getting registered for tomorrow
morning's trade room is pretty darn easy
easy as falling off a shetland pony as
they say just easy as falling off a
shetland pony
now guys who is this man probably a lot
of you guys haven't heard of him
well he runs a channel called school of
trade
uh now i think it's been shifted to
joseph james or something like that but
it used to be school of trade and as you
can see the site
is still branded that way why do i bring
this guy up and why is he in throwback
thursday well it's because of what
happened to him
in 2017. see this video is from
yesterday
like he's still selling this course
right now but you know what happened
in 2017
this man paid 4.9 million dollars in
trading system
fraud and as you can see the thing that
says fraud on it
literally has not changed see the u.s
commodity futures trading commission
charged this guy with paying restitution
to defrauded investors totaling
4 million and a 1 million dollar penalty
for doing what he did now i won't read
all of this to you but basically
uh this guy was not really making the
money he said he was making with his
course
and so they find him now obviously has
the course changed a lot i mean we can
just kind of go off of this
what do you think if this is what the
course looked like before
and of course he's selling now today
right now
after paying four million dollars back
to investors and one million dollars
to the government it still looks like
this what's the point
guys these people don't stop even when
they're caught
they don't stop and let's look at this
comment section
i've been watching you since may 2020
when i started training so a new trader
here you think he has any
idea of what happened with the cftc jay
joseph james is your mentor traitor
priceless dreams come true 2021
good stuff jj hey thanks for the video
this is a guy who was convicted by the
cftc and forced to pay a penalty
for what he was selling and he's still
selling it and people
are still buying it which goes to the
irrationality
of people who are both scamming and also
something we don't talk about
is being scammed there's an allure to
the person
scamming we can't ignore that guys we
can't just pretend these people are
clowns which a lot of them are
but at the highest level the best
scammers they have a real like
magnetism to them and you know this
isn't about you know your small-time
gurus this is about people like this
this is
kevin trudeau ladies and gentlemen if
you don't know who that is that's
because he's been in jail
for contempt of court among other things
he had a lot of run-ins with the
government for
selling his shady products he was also
always telling you
you're gonna have the mega mind memory
you're gonna have
he sold that course he sold like weight
loss cures he sold like
money making cures basically he's always
selling something else
and every time it didn't live up to the
hype so kevin trudeau eventually was
silenced he ignored the court
he got arrested right so classic scammer
but this man even now after being in
jail for years
still has people die hard supporting
this man
to the point where there's an entire
group of people
that are trying to free kevin trudeau
early and they send him
money uh to his mailing address at
prison
and they send him letters like he's got
a whole fan club that have followed him
even into jail
they're basically worse than bts fanboys
and fan girls okay
these people love this guy despite the
fact
that his products did not work now of
course a few people are going to say
well i tried his weight loss thing i
injected myself with hgh or whatever it
was and oh i lost 10 pounds
this guy was a known con man but yet
he had a magnetism to him
it's hard it's easy to dismiss these
guys as oh kooky whatever
scammers they are but there's something
kind of there as well
that's very interesting to think about
because if you're going to protect
yourself and others
you can't think these people are going
to show up telling you they're going to
scam you
or going oh ha ha i'm going to get you
if you guys
met this guy that [ __ ] you probably like
him that's the thing
many of you may know that years and
years ago back in actually 1989
i did a program called mega memory it
became one of the most popular
self-improvement series of all time
when i did that program mega memory one
of the things i did was
i made a big decision to expose
both corporate and government corruption
and particularly at that time
i was exposing how the department of
education was trying to force
the drug ritalin oh yeah so that's
actually like
how okay this is great so this is what a
lot of people do
is they tie themselves to causes while
scamming you
right so while getting these fees while
riding around in yachts and boats and
luxury cars
this guy's basically saying hey i was
trying to help the common man i'm trying
to expose everybody exposing big pharma
exposing all this stuff so they play on
your biases so
this is pretty long but basically he
says you know i'm this big victim who's
been
cheated uh and even when you go to a lot
of the videos
where he's being exposed they have a
bunch of down votes on him because all
kevin trudeau's fans
don't want to believe it here's one of
the videos
uh controversial tv pitch man kevin
trudeau jail he's got like
25 down votes and then the top comments
are basically like free kevin trudeau
things it's so sad that the government
will frame someone as a scammer
and use major media to convince the
public it's like dude the guy
is a scammer this is in a video by the
way which exposes kevin for running yet
another scam
of this like membership club or whatever
which then he says oh i
i don't have any control over are you
using gin
as a personal piggy bank to live a
really lavish lifestyle
and avoid paying this judgment well i
think that's a legitimate question but
even if i was
what's the point i'm screwed i can't own
anything for the rest of my life
so i'm not going to start a company and
put it in my own name
it'd be dumb and i certainly can go to
friends relatives neighbors or whatever
and say listen
you start a company and i'll help you
out and there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing illegal about it and
guess
what it ain't my asset that argument may
put you in jail we'll see
i have an insane yeah it might put you
in jail kevin
uh i think time is told on that subject
moving on from this we're going to talk
about another uh
con man who has really just rebounded
shockingly well from his scandal you
know brian rose has really
totally given up the idea of ever
pursuing the digital freedom platform or
making that a thing
in fact if you go to the donation page
for brian rose
you know that thing the big freedom
platform he was pushing now it just
redirects to his mayoral campaign he's
completely forgotten about it
is he gonna sue google is he gonna get
free speech back nah don't worry about
that now he's running for mayor
so he's completely grifted everybody
that money's gone it's been scammed and
yet
when you go to his videos the comment
section which used to be all dislikes
is back to what it used to be like no
scandal
everybody here is just agreeing with
brian and um
you find out that he doesn't really
doesn't really suffer any consequences
for it
this is like a bitter pill to swallow if
you get really invested in this stuff
and
it's why i really stopped getting
invested in what happens i just try to
save people
from these scams but at the end of the
day if you look across history
of scammers and how their career goes
they will
always have victims kevin trudeau when
he gets out of jail soon
you think he's gonna go on the straight
and narrow all of a sudden hell
no he's gonna go right back to pitch him
baby pitching new stuff
i guarantee it i think he's about to get
out of jail and i think this will be
borne out
napoleon hill even if people knew that
he was a scammer back then
what happened people still followed him
you got school of trading
gets indicted by the cftc or you know
pays all these penalties what's he still
doing he's still selling the course
people are still watching the videos
it's hard to understand uh from
our perspective but we have to
understand it nonetheless because i
think it gives us an insight into human
psychology
we like people who sell us the dream
we like people who are narcissistic
who say they have all of the answers
it's tough
you know what it's not just brian rose
goes to the tippity-tippity top
we've got a old d trump you guys know
him
and listen i'm not getting relax hey a
lot of you guys
uh you shrank back on me just now in
your seats you go wait wait a second
wait a second what's he gonna say
about d trump i'm just gonna say this
we're keeping it not political guys
we're keeping it away from politics
just look at what he did before politics
before having anything to do with
politics he was running a scam with
acn which is a multi-level marketing
company
where he endorsed them it's a great
relationship with acn
and the more i learned about them the
more i like and respect them
okay uh he ran a scam with
trump university we have amish to tell
us all about that he also ran trump
network his
own pyramid scheme right and yet each
time you know
he'd have to have victims of course but
he just kept
just moving on didn't care and he
keeps moving on and guess what
eventually he eventually gets the white
house
and you know what he's still doing it
because he sends me
i'm on his emailing list i'm on trump's
emailing list yeah i'm a big deal guys
president emails me
uh he's always trying to get money from
all his people on his email list
and he keeps saying hey if you donate
now i'll give you a thousand percent
matching on your donation
now is there any truth to that no that's
a total lie and a known scam
by politicians which is somehow legal
where they tell you that your
your donation is going to get a thousand
percent matched it's a complete
demonstrable lie and you know we don't
care we move on
and the reason i'm telling you guys this
is not to bum you out it's not to it's
not to make you sad
it's to help equip you for understanding
the trajectory
of con artistry and to help you
understand don't try to
end con artists forever people always
ask me you know how can we help shut
them down
i don't know the to ask the federal
government to do more they they really
don't
they don't do a lot but until then you
can just
inform people if they don't listen they
don't listen just inform your friends
don't let you know your family get
involved in these things but other than
that that's basically all you can do
because at the end of the day
there's something psychologically
irresistible
about con men to most people and it's
just
it's a hard truth about life and to
close this off i want you to just
listen to donald trump pitch the trump
network because i think it's a great
case study in how selling the dream
even when you know it's a scam can be
compelling because they prey on
your existing insecurities they pray off
the injustices
in the world you're going to hear him
talk about how unfair it is that you
don't have a fair shake at life
and how he just wants to help you so try
to listen to this uh
trump pitch with fresh eyes because if
you can understand the psychological
manipulation behind this if you can
understand
why this works you're not gonna have to
watch another coffeezilla video again i
hope you will
but yeah i hope you learned something
i'll let this play out i'll see you next
time
hello i'm donald trump and welcome to
the trump network
i want you to know why i'm so excited to
be a part of this great organization
at no time in recent history has our
economy been in a state
that it is today it's a mess the
economic meltdown
greed and ineptitude in the financial
industry have sabotaged the dreams of
millions of people
americans need a new plan they need
a new dream the trump network wants to
give millions of people
renewed hope and with an exciting plan
to
opt out of the recession let's get out
of this recession
right now with cutting edge health and
wellness formulas and a system where you
can develop your own financial
independence
the trump network offers people the
opportunity to achieve their american
dream
i'm still looking for dreams i'm doing
damn well in life
but i'm still looking for the dream it's
a winning combination because it means
you
and your family can benefit financially
from our breakthrough program
follow our step-by-step success system
that will help you grow your business
this journey is going to be a fantastic
one and you're going to have a lot of
fun
the trump network is positioned to help
millions of people
overcome the recession and achieve the
success they've always dreamed of
i hope you're going to join us it's
going to be fun
and hopefully very profitable
you